what's up everybody today we've got
something special for you guys we have
destroy all humans 2
reprobed edition yes now on my left over
here this was from the destroy all
humans dna collectors edition and it
came with a wonderful really good scale
statue with a lot of details a nice
squishy little alien yeah
and of course the little diorama of
crypto
and the ufo with a
cow
so let's go ahead and check out all the
contents in the destroy all humans 2 we
probed the second coming edition
all right so let's take a quick tour of
what we have
in the box right here we've got the
title of course and a very nice 60s font
behold he comes inside here we have let
crypto into your homes or fear the wrath
of his sources mighty death ray thou
shall not have any other alien overlord
and of course the content page here and
as well as the side all right so taking
off the sleeve
all right so we have
essentially two different boxes
see the top here i believe this is the
statue
all right
so
gpu
eq comes out like this
so the first thing we have
[Music]
is the great ark wobble
oh
it's better known as the ark woodle he
is
the lord of the sacred crotch
he is
a bobble head
check it out
so here is a furon god from what i know
uh yeah
very nice check out the details on that
[Music]
next up we have the
skin packs
and the other dlcs we also have the
certificate
of authenticity because only 3
700 of these
second coming editions
are available worldwide so this is your
certificate of authenticity right here
cool
it says here this is definitely not an
invasive space fungus we taught to
imitate a certificate and that will
awake when you're in contact with the
earth's atmosphere to crawl up one of
your many human cavities pinky promise
and of course the art of destroyer
humans too we probe so
very nice and thick art book
check out all these cool skins and
concepts they have
have the destroyer all humans 2 we probe
official soundtrack
and it comes in a disc
check out the disc if you wanted to
here
and of course the base copy of the game
let's take a look at this tattooer
all right folks here we go
taking this out you've got a little bit
of instructions there's some assembly
required and we're going to show you how
to do that
so all right so what we have here is the
lithographic
plate of crypto one three eight arc
voodoo says come again two hesitations
verse 6 chapter 9 behold he comes
it's very cool and i don't know whether
you can catch this on camera but
um it's embossed
here and if you got like displayed
magnets you can just stick it on the
wall and stuff it's it's pretty light
yeah so a little bit of some
instructions here from when i can tell
[Applause]
we've got the base which is actually
coming from the side over here this is
the groovy base
that holds crypto 138 it has a nice
peace sign because
it's this rocking 60s man for those who
want to check out the instructions over
here
you got this side
okay
and then this is just the top of the
anal probe
wow it does look really different
okay so we've got the body over here
let me bring it to you guys
this is the body
pretty much the same colorway i think
crypto137 is a little bit more on the
bluish hue over there
uh and you've got some remodeled design
on his
forearm over here
uh he has a chest piece now
yeah so a little bit of a redesign in
terms of what he's wearing
so that's tier one tier two
will be
the head
oh yeah
um
interesting
i think
like so
yeah skin tone is a little bit different
the brains are definitely different
of course the very cool inner pro gun
just half of it
transparent
right there
cool
this pops in very easy plug and play
and to top off the ending of
the inner pro
boom we're done
alrighty so before we kick off the
comparison i forgot to lock this in so
please don't do what i'm doing right now
two tabs just got twisted to lock it in
and there you go he won't get out now
so let's talk about what you get
compared to the dna
collector's edition
three items here two items based on
physical collectibles
um alone so
unfortunately i wish they had more i
wish they had a different diorama like
what they had in the dna collectors
edition
it's very cool all right in fact if we
turn off the lights
it glows in the dark so what i have here
is a uv torch light very cool and in the
moment you're gonna see
once i charge this up it actually glows
in the dark
and boom
so with dark voodoo here it doesn't look
like glows in the dark but what's very
interesting is that you kind of see a
different pattern
on the statue which is pretty cool let
me just turn this
that's pretty interesting in terms of
the statue nothing's happening
with crypto 137 and what about
crypto138 he has some
glowy paint parts
all around so he got his chest piece
and his forearm as well as his knee
guards
the base kind of reacts i'm not sure
whether it's reactive paint and turning
to the back you can see that he has
small striations here yellow on his
thighs
on his jet pack
on his forearm once again and of course
his shoulder pads first of all let's
talk about the sculpting between these
two i feel that crypto138 is a much
better sculpt so let's take a look at
the sides here and just focus on
the side of the brains i still prefer
crypto 137's brain
he has more
veins in his brain so he can it makes it
look more real
whereas crypto 138 you just got like
three
or two big big veins
you can clearly see that at the back of
crypto one through seven one three eight
they have different life support systems
or jet packs if you will other than that
actually very similar
hits
just that krypto137 has a hollow mouth
so you can actually see through his
teeth
and i can peek through the other side
whereas
crystal 138 is just painted on
and of course you can't forget about the
eyes the eyes are very special both of
them are pretty much the same
here but i just love the way it's dotted
around red and black you can also see at
the base of the foot here you're
starting to see more details so you got
the big toe and then the smaller toes
here
and let's just focus on the weapons here
for crypto 137 is the disintegrator ray
now these are all hand painted so you
do see imperfections in the in the way
it's weathered and it's painted
but with crypto one three it is even
more clean looking and i love the mix of
materials here with the the plastic
canister
over here
and and the more angular design another
cool feature that crypto137 had was they
can pop off the globe and you know fit
all little gizmos like
cereal and digestive crackers
yeah you never know when you need them
right
we have with crypto138 the cool thing
about the alien probe is that you can
stuff more crap pun intended
into the garden
for instance
more graham crackers
just oh my god it fits
so for 400
is it worth the price well for starters
if you are a fan of destroyer humans and
you just want to collect something so
massive at this skill i think it's
already worth the price by itself not to
mention that there are other physical
collectibles coming in from this box the
game the dlc's and other bonus contents
so yes
get it and if you're gonna get one for
yourselves do let us know in the
comments down below like and subscribe
and if you like to see more collector
unboxings check out these videos in
there right crypto138
yes like and subscribe and look for more
of our videos here in geek culture
you puny humans
yes click
click on it
click
[Music]